[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt es einen meiner Lieblingskuchen,
nämlich einen Kirschstreuselkuchen.
Eigentlich ein recht einfacher Kuchen,
aber ich habe den tatsächlich noch nicht auf meinem Kanal.
Wird allerhöchste Zeit!
Es ein richtig schöner Sonntagskuchen.
Nein, ich finde eigentlich den Begriff Sonntagskuchen blöd,
weil ganz ehrlich: Kuchen geht die ganze Woche.
Hallo Muffin.
Zuerst werde ich jetzt einmal die Kirschfüllung zubereiten.
Dafür nehme ich Kirschen aus dem Glas.
Ihr könnt aber auch frische Kirschen nehmen,
die ihr dann noch entsteinen müsst.
Aber so, muss ich sagen, habe ich immer alles in meinem Vorratsschrank
und kann den Kuchen auch jederzeit zubereiten.
Für die Kirschfüllung habe ich hier schon einmal
die Kirschen abtropfen lassen,
das Wasser aufgefangen und dieses dann auf 500 ml mit Wasser aufgefüllt.
D.h., ich habe hier 500 ml Kirschsaft mit Wasser,
die Kirschen aus dem Glas, 50 g Stärke und 40 g Zucker.
Jetzt nehme ich die Flüssigkeit, die hier in einen Topf kommt
- kann ich auch schon aufkochen
und hier in der Restflüssigkeit die Stärke und den Zucker verrühren.
[Musik]
Sobald der Saft kocht, einfach die Puddingmischung einrühren
und noch einmal schön aufkochen lassen.
Da kommen jetzt auch die Kirschen dazu und werden nur noch kurz eingerührt.
Dann ist die Füllung fertig.
Ich fülle das Ganze jetzt auch um, damit es schnell abkühlt.
Wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr das Ganze auch verfeinern,
mit z.B. Amaretto oder Bittermandelaroma
- falls ihr da einfach gerne noch einen Geschmack mit reinnehmen möchtet.
Wenn ihr das Ganze z.B. im Winter zubereitet,
könnte auch Zimt ganz gut passen,
ein bisschen Zitronenabrieb, bisschen Nelken, Kardamom
- was ihr ebenso gerne habt.
Ich nehme jetzt doch Tonka Wonka rein.
Das passt immer gut.
Oh, die ist noch verschlossen. [Lacht]
JOSH: Explodiert…
SALLY: Ja… ich drück so und dann…
[Spannende Musik]
[Beide lachen]
Oh!
JOSH: Den Inhalt der Tube, nicht die Tube rein!
SALLY: Oh! Oh nein!
[TikTok-Sound nachgemacht] Oh no, oh no…
Ich mache einmal kurz die Tube sauber,
stelle die Füllung zur Seite
und zeige euch die Zutaten für den Mürbteig.
Ups. [Lacht]
Dafür nehme ich 130 g Zucker, 260 g kalte Butter, 390 g Mehl,
etwas Salz, 1 Eigelb und Vanilleextrakt.
Den Mürbteig könnt ihr jetzt mit den Händen, mit einem Messer,
mit einem Mürbteigzerhacker oder auch mit der Küchenmaschine zubereiten.
Hier ist einfach wichtig: Die Butter sollte wirklich schön kalt sein.
Ich verknete jetzt erst einmal Butter und Zucker.
[Küchenmaschine]
Dann kommt das Mehl mit dazu
und der Teig sollte jetzt wirklich recht schnell verarbeitet werden,
dass er eben auch schön kalt bleibt.
Salz und Vanille gebe ich auch noch dazu.
So, jetzt ist der Teig erst einmal fertig.
Den verwende ich jetzt praktisch für die Streusel obendrauf,
aber auch für den Boden.
Ich nehme jetzt einmal ein Drittel davon raus,
so ungefähr ein Drittel.
Das kommt als Streusel obendrauf.
Hier rühre ich jetzt noch das Eigelb ein.
Das braucht man im Prinzip nicht,
denn der Teig hält auch so ganz gut zusammen,
aber für euch auch zur Sicherheit,
dass einfach der Keksboden sozusagen schön hält,
ihn auch schön formen könnt, ist das Eigelb für die Bindung schon ganz gut.
Wenn ihr das Ganze vegan zubereiten wollt…
Das ist auch gar kein Problem,
denn die Füllung ist sowieso vegan.
Hier im Teig könnt ihr dann praktisch vegane Butter verwenden
und wirklich das Ei weglassen.
Es macht fast keinen Unterschied
- es ist nur für die Handhabung einfacher
und könnt den Kuchen praktisch komplett vegan zubereiten.
[Küchenmaschine]
Das war's schon.
Jetzt habe ich hier schon eine Backform auf 25 cm eingestellt,
habe das Ganze hier auf dem Lochblech mit der Dauerbackfolie.
So einen Streuselkuchen kann man nämlich wunderbar
einfach in so einem Ring backen.
Die backen dann auch schön gleichmäßig durch,
weil eben dieses Lochblech für eine perfekte Hitzeverteilung sorgt,
da einfach von unten und oben gleichmäßig die Hitze drankommen kann
und man kann den Ring eben individuell einstellen.
Das ist auch immer ganz praktisch,
weil ihr den Kuchen z.B.
auch in 20 cm Größe zubereiten könnt
und einfach in meiner App die Zutaten umrechnen lassen könnt
oder auch das Ganze z.B.
eckig backen könnt.
Einfach in die App gehen, eckige Backform eingeben und dann wird alles eben
umgerechnet. Jetzt nehmt ihr hier den Teig.
Der ist jetzt noch schön kalt.
Ich forme jetzt erst einmal solche Rollen,
um einen 3 cm hohen Rand zu ziehen.
Anlegen und einfach fest drücken.
[Musik]
Um den Rand hier ein bisschen schöner und dünner zu machen,
könnt ihr auch ein Glas nehmen
und dann das Ganze echt so schön andrücken.
Den Rest nehmt ihr jetzt einfach und füllt den Boden der Form aus.
[Musik]
Ihr könnt jetzt, wenn ihr wollt,
den Rand noch schön perfekt z.B. mit einem Messer zuschneiden,
dass er schön gerade ist.
Aber ich finde, so ein bisschen handmade darf er schon aussehen.
Jetzt kommt hier die etwas abgekühlte Kirschfüllung drauf.
[Musik]
Und da kommen jetzt die Streusel drauf.
Ich habe mich jetzt noch dazu entschlossen, gehobelte Mandeln drauf zu streuen
- könnt ihr auch gern machen.
Oder gehackte Mandel oder Haselnüsse dürft ihr auch gern im Teig mit verarbeiten,
aber ich finde dieses Rezept ist einfach so ein Basic-Rezept,
was man eben mal schnell machen kann.
Ich habe bis jetzt nicht länger als 20 Min. gebraucht, vielleicht 30…
Und ab in den Backofen.
[Uhr]
[Musik]
Jetzt ist der Kirchstreuselkuchen gebacken und ausgekühlt.
Ich habe ihn jetzt gerade noch mit süßem Schnee bestreut.
Das ist der Puderzucker, der nicht schmilzt.
Da ich mich echt schon seit Wochen auf diesen Kirschkuchen freue,
werde ich ihn alleine probieren. Ich hoffe, das ist okay für alle.
[„Nein" aus dem Hintergrund]
Natürlich teile ich gleich mit euch…
Aber eins…
Was soll ich sagen?
Ich freue mich echt schon. Der Kuchen steht schon gefühlt…
Nein, nicht gefühlt. Der steht schon, ich glaube, seit 4 Monaten auf meiner
To-Do-Liste und ich habe ihn einfach nie zubereitet.
Und jetzt freue ich mich drauf,
dass ich das Rezept mit euch teilen kann.
Ich genieße gleich mein Stück Kuchen.
Ich mag den vor allem frisch gebacken,
weil dann die Crumble einfach noch richtig Crunchy und knusprig sind.
Die Füllung ist perfekt.
Also probiert ihn gerne aus.
Der ist auch nicht so süß, muss ich sagen,
ist schnell zu machen. ist immer ein toller Kuchen für einen Geburtstag,
für sonntags, für Montag bis Freitag - egal wann,
auch am Samstag natürlich - ist auch ein Samstagskuchen.
Den Wochentag wollen wir natürlich nicht auslassen.
Ihr könnt ihr ja einmal schreiben, was euer Lieblingskuchen ist,
so als klassischer Kuchen.
Ich werde jetzt in Joshs Worten sagen:
Was ist euer Lieblingsklassiker unter den Kuchen?
Auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10
muss er schon mindestens eine 5 sein.
[Lacht] Oder?
JOSH: Ja, das kommt schon gut hin.
Und der Kuchen ist für mich auf jeden Fall schon einmal eine 9!
Also wirklich! Wirklich!
Mürbteig, Crumble, Füllung, fruchtig
- das ist echt eine 9 für mich.
Also probiert ihn gern aus!
Rezept gibt's auf www.Sallys-Blog.de oder in meiner App
und bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss!
[Musik]